as a sort of general idea on the program
I hesitate to do segments where I just
cheer a religious leader when they step
just outside of the normal dogma of
their religion it's a something that for
most rational thinkers would be pretty
obvious because in a way I feel like it
encourages us to keep paying attention
to what religious leaders say about
society it kind of lends importance to
what a particular religious community
thinks about an issue and I don't know
that that's something I want to do but
at the same time especially when we're
talking about the Catholic Church for
example which has more than a billion
followers it actually does impact the
worldview of many people when the Pope
some says something that's notable or
unusual in some way and over the last
few days there have just been a ton of
headlines about Pope Francis told a gay
man who was sexually abused that God
made him gay and that God didn't mind
that he was gay but the reason I want to
talk about it is not because of the
amazingly great thing that it is that
Pope Francis said this I mean it's a
fine thing to say I actually don't think
it's notable unique or new in any way
and I'll explain to you what I mean this
abuse victim had a private meeting with
the Pope a couple of weeks ago and was
on the receiving end of what appears to
be according to the articles that are
being written like the most Pro gay
comments from a pope maybe in the
history of the Catholic Church and the
man said he told me you were that you
are gay does not matter
God made you like this and loves you
like this and I don't care
the Pope loves you like this you have to
be happy with who you are the church was
asked that did the Pope really say this
to this guy and they haven't commented
but there have been no denials for sure
so again it's great that the leader of
such a major religion seems to be saying
number one you were born gay God made
you gay is kind of like saying you were
born gay which is better than saying
people choose to be gay which is a
common religious right idea that's good
but at the same time the church has for
a long time focused on the actions and
the sin rather than the sinner right
it's always been about everybody is
God's child and bump up up above but
don't go and have gay sex because that's
really bad and you could
up in hell for all of eternity so I
actually am having a hard time even
agreeing that this is some blockbuster
thing like he basically said God loves
everybody and everybody is the way God
intended them to be nobody as no people
are aberrations but still leaving out of
the discussion that it's the actions
that can be aberrant and it's always
sort of been the sin not the sinner for
the Catholic Church that is the concern
so I just don't think this is notable
yeah I mean buying into their worldview
there would be a pretty cruel thing for
God to do right because you're making
this person gay and you know fulfilling
them with all these desires but then if
they try to act upon them then they
could face eternal repercussions right
burn in hell for all of eternity
I guess they would say it was so so
that's that let's explore that right the
idea would be why would God make someone
gay but sentenced them to hell if they
act on the gay impulses that God gave
them seems almost like cruel in some way
right it's test I guess they'd say God
is always testing us each one of us in
different ways or the completely
meaningless umbrella term God works in
mysterious ways which is of course of no
value whatsoever and completely not
defeasible but you bring a Fitbit now by
the way I think I just noticed that I'm
now wearing a Fitbit that I don't get
much recorded during the show he glared
right against my my eye now I realize
that Pat's wearing a Fitbit but that'll
W story for a different time so listen I
mean it's not clear that this is
actually notable being gay has always
been less the issue for the Catholic
Church having gay sex acting on the gay
impulses is sort of what's always been
the problem so in the end is this even
something that the secular community who
of course believes religion should be
allowed to exist assuming it doesn't
interfere with public policy or
government action should the secular
community even address the comings and
goings of what a particular religion
says I don't know I feel like it's
notable only in the sense that the
Catholic Church has so many followers
but at the same time it's not it's just
a new spin on what the Catholic Church
has always said which is hateful sin not
the sinner it's a step in the right
direction I guess I feel like the trend
is because now we have such a
progressive Pope and Pope Francis that
he'll say something sensible and then
the church will walk it back oh he
didn't actually mean
that we've seen happen yeah like with
his comments on how maybe hell doesn't
exist after all and then 50 years from
now once this is no longer even the
slightest bit of a controversial issue
they'll say well will we support it you
know being gay and this idea that hell
doesn't exist all along yeah friends
said it 50 years ago right 2018 Pope
Francis told the guy God doesn't hate
him or something like that I guess my
bigger question is am i doing a service
or disservice to the overall discussion
around these social issues when I even
mentioned Pope Francis said a B or C
that I guess is what I'd be curious to
hear from the audience right like is it
is this notable in a way that it has a
place on this program which advocates
for separation of church and state in
accordance with the sort of founding
principles of the United States of
America or is it just the sort of fluff
let me know I'm open to hearing from
people one way or the other the video
you just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as $1 per
month and every dollar helps to support
the work that we're doing particularly
in light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad